good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm on my
way to get a tattoo so wake I'm here
outside of Firefly tattoo with rosianna
and I am going to get an inkless tattoo
as a punishment because apparently in
2012 I did something punishable and then
you and nerdfighteria dredged it up
because you like to see me suffer
slightly off topic Hank but I just saw
the television program Firefly for the
first time it is excellent how did they
cancel that so this is Laura my tattoo
artist I have a couple questions what is
the least painful place to get an
inquest tattoo anyway that you've got
some good muscle underneath it are my
bicep this is huge muscles there you go
all right I think I just wanted to say
get to be on my upper arm I actually
brought a shirt to change into me can
you tell what I'm an anxious person are
you just gonna oh this is not a tattoo
this is a pen marker okay okay I've seen
those before working on but you know
what I don't even want to look at that
scared I'm gonna be honest word that
hurts a little bit is it going to hurt
women
am I the most anxious tattoo recipient
you've ever had in your career you I'm
honored
okay it is have you ever gonna make this
tattoo oh sweet Jesus that doesn't hurt
at all
hey I think I might sort of like getting
tattoos I feel like I could read a book
while this is happening
do they really so inquire made my dftba
tattoo with water instead of ink meaning
that it's going to go away in about a
month and I have to say that while I
spent the last several weeks fearing
this punishment it turned out to be the
least punishing vlogbrothers punishment
ever in fact I really loved the tattoo
itself especially in all of its
impermanence I mean dftba are after all
the five most important letters in my
life update just realize that both of my
children have five letter names so I
would like to amend my previous
statement but anyway war made the whole
process relaxing and fun and pretty
painless we just chatted for a while and
then suddenly are you serious
it's over hey look at my awesome tattoo
now I want to get a real tattoo I got to
talk to my wife the first I can't
believe it's over that was so fast and
easy and relatively fun I'm not saying
get a tattoo I'm just saying it's fast
and easy and fun anyway Hank as it says
on my arm
don't forget to be awesome I'll see you
on Friday